Salut !
Vous avez peut-être cliqué sur cette vidéo
à cause de son titre légèrement clickbait…
Mais quel est votre profil ?
Je vois trois grandes options.
vous êtes abonné.e à ma chaîne et vous
aimez bien ce que je propose. Vous avez donc
un a priori plutôt positif. Vous vous demandez
ce que je vais bien pouvoir raconter pour
défendre l’astrologie
Vous n’êtes pas abonné.e à ma chaîne,
vous êtes plutôt prêt.e à croire à l’astrologie
et vous espérez trouver dans ma vidéo des
arguments pour la défendre face aux nombreuses
attaques venues des sceptiques
Vous n’êtes pas abonné.e à ma chaîne,
vous vous reconnaissez dans le scepticisme
ou la zététique et vous vous demandez quel
tissu d’absurdités j’ai bien pu imaginer
pour défendre l’astrologie.
Alors je crois que le plus simple, c’est
de commencer par préciser l’enjeu de cette
vidéo… et donc de justifier ce titre légèrement
racoleur.
Je ne vais pas vous proposer une plongée
rigoureuse au cœur de l’astrologie, comme
pour en révéler des dimensions inconnues
du grand public, et par là défendre une
nouvelle validité prétendument scientifique.
On sait que l’astrologie est une cible préférentielle
pour les sceptiques. Comme tout ce qui est
lié, de près ou de loin au New Age.
Je ne vais pas attaquer les contenus sceptiques
qui se sont attachés à «débunker»
l’astrologie. Je sais que Christopher Michel
de la chaîne Hygiène Mentale s’y est attelé.
Je sais que Serge Bret-Morel en a fait le
cœur de son activité sceptique.
Il est important de préciser d’emblée
que :
je reconnais la validité des critiques
En fait, je vais parler très peu d’astrologie.
En un sens, on peut dire que cette vidéo
concerne tout autant le Tarot. Ce qui m’intéresse,
c’est de questionner la relation qu’on
a à ce type de discours. Parce que le thème
astral comme le tirage de cartes, sont des
discours. Des formes de «paroles magiques»,
censées nous révéler quelque chose.   Et
je me demande si les critiques qu’on formule
à l’égard de ces discours ne manquent
pas, malgré leur validité formelle, une
certaine dimension. S’il n’y a pas une
autre manière de voir l’astrologie, le
tarot, etc.
Deuxième chose à préciser : je reconnais
la dangerosité potentielle des pratiques
susceptibles de générer ce qu’on pourrait
appeler «l’effet guru».
Ici, par «effet guru», je veux parler
de situations spécifiques où un individu
jouit d’une position dominante, du fait
qu’on lui attribue une espèce de supériorité
indéniable, parfois quasi surnaturelle.
Il devient alors très facile pour cet individu
de profiter de cette position et de manipuler
celles et ceux qui lui font confiance aveuglément.
Mais il me tient vraiment à cœur de préciser
tout de suite : je déteste parler de «guru»
pour désigner ces individus. C’est-à-dire,
au fond, dans un contexte occidental.
Le concept de guru dans les spiritualités
indiennes est d’une grande complexité.
D’ailleurs, il ne désigne pas nécessairement
une personne. Je trouve insultant de récupérer
ce terme pour le réduire à une insulte signifiant
peu ou prou : leader de secte pratiquant l’endoctrinement.
et parler « d’effet marabout» pour désigner
les situations où quelqu’un profite de
la crédulité d’une personne pour le manipuler
à son avantage soulève exactement le même
problème relativement aux cultures musulmanes
africaines.
Comment faudrait-il appeler ça ? Si vous
avez des idées, n’hésitez pas à les partager
en commentaire.
Bref, tout ça pour dire que oui, il y a sûrement
un danger potentiel lié à l’astrologie,
analogue à celui qu’incarnent les mediums.
Et je ne veux pas nier ce danger.
La question que je pose ici est plus large
: quel rapport à la croyance le rejet de
ces pratiques révèle-t-il ? Nos critiques
ne passent-elles pas à côté de quelque
chose ? L’approche sceptique est-elle la
plus pertinente ? N’est-elle pas réductrice
?
Bref, vous l’avez compris, c’est l’hypothèse
que je vais défendre ici. Et j’irai même
jusqu’à dire que cette approche, cette
manière de critiquer ces pratiques, incarne
un potentiel danger pour la pensée.
C’est ce que je veux partager avec vous
aujourd’hui.
Parce que c’est bien là la raison d’être
de cette chaîne.
Je ne prétends éduquer personne. Je ne suis
expert en rien et ne fais pas, en ce sens,
de vulgarisation.
Je suis admiratif de celles et ceux qui, sur
twitter ou sur youtube, rendent accessible
des contenus complexes pour une audience avide
de nourriture intellectuelle.
Celles et ceux qui permettent une éducation
populaire, en somme.
Je n’ai pas les moyens de proposer un tel
type de contenu. Ce n’est pas comme ça
que cette chaîne fonctionne.
Tout ce que je propose, ce sont des idées,
des réflexions, des cheminements… et vous
seul savez si ce contenu vous intéresse.
Un objectif de cette chaîne, c’est de montrer
qu’il y a toujours «une autre manière
de voir les choses». J’ai envie de nourrir
notre capacité à imaginer qu’il existe
une autre perspective, une autre façon de
comprendre le monde.
On pourrait dire qu’il s’agit de générer
de l’humilité épistémique.
Bref, où est-ce que je veux en venir avec
l’astrologie, le tarot, et compagnie ?
Je veux dire que notre relation à ces pratiques
est révélatrice d’un certain rapport à
la croyance et à la connaissance.
Je vois beaucoup de similitudes entre celui
qui y croit et celle qui n’y croit pas.
Au fond, même si les conclusions sont contraires,
leur disposition d’esprit ont beaucoup en
commun. C’est ce que je voudrais montrer
en premier lieu.
1) CROYANCE & RÉALITÉ
Il faut commencer par poser la question plus
générale de la croyance.
Qu’est-ce que croire ?
il semblerait que selon la définition intuitive
la plus communément partagée, «croire»,
c’est, en gros, «tenir pour vrai».
Si je crois qu’il y a un stylo dans mon
tiroir, c’est que je tiens pour vrai qu’il
y a un stylo dans mon tiroir.
Mais on peut essayer de présenter le phénomène
mental de la croyance un peu plus précisément.
Par exemple, on peut envisager la croyance
comme une représentation. C’est-à-dire,
tout simplement, que toute croyance s’accompagne
d’une sorte d’image mentale, qui correspond
à la proposition, c’est-à-dire à la phrase
de la croyance.
En l’occurrence, pour reprendre l’exemple
: j’aurais, dans ma tête, une image du
stylo dans le tiroir.
C’est la position qu’on appelle représentationnaliste.
Il y a aussi le dispositionnalisme : pour
cette posture philosophique, ce qui est essentiel
au fait de croire, c’est d’adopter un
comportement qui correspond à la croyance.
Pour le dire simplement, ce qui fait que je
crois qu’il y a un stylo dans le tiroir,
ce n’est pas que j’ai une image du stylo
dans le tiroir dans mon esprit, c’est que
j’ouvre le tiroir pour y prendre le stylo.
L’exemple qu’on trouve dans l’encyclopédie
Stanford est éclairant : imaginons un extra-terrestre,
qui atterrit en France et intègre normalement
la société, paye ses impôts, milite dans
des associations et est fan de rugby.
Même si on ne sait rien de ce qui se passe
dans sa tête, il paraîtrait normal de considérer
que cet extra-terrestre «croit» qu’il
doit faire sa déclaration d’impôts en
mai, qu’un essai transformé vaut 7 points.
Aucunement besoin de projeter un contenu mental
similaire à celui des humains.
Pour éviter tout malentendu, parce que je
reconnais que mon illustration peut susciter
des quiproquos :
On imagine que E-T regarde un match France
- Afrique du Sud. L’équipe de France est
menée de 6 points et à dans les dernières
minutes, marque un essai et le transforme.
L’E-T bondit de joie. Son comportement que
l’E-T nous permet de déduire qu’il croit,
comme le reste des supporters, que l’équipe
de France est passée devant et va gagner
le match.
Son comportement révèle sa croyance.
Cette première distinction est intéressante
à mes yeux au moins pour une raison.
Si on s’en tient à l’approche représentationnaliste,
on peut «croire qu’on croit» quelque
chose, parce qu’on a une représentation
mentale de cette croyance. Et l’approche
dispositionnaliste peut révéler une croyance
contraire, parce que notre comportement contredit
l’image qu’on a dans la tête.
C’est fréquent pour ce qui est de la politique
: Bob croit sincèrement qu’il n’est pas
raciste, parce que quand il fait une introspection,
il ne trouve rien, dans son contenu mental,
qui s’apparente au racisme, à ce qu’il
imagine être raciste. Voire même, il se
pense contre le racisme. Tandis qu’on peut
déceler dans son comportement une expression
de condescendance, de paternalisme ou toute
attitude qui révèle, en creux, une tendance
aux clichés, à la généralisation, voire
tout simplement une conception inégale des
cultures, et donc une forme de racisme.
J’aime l’idée que ce que l’on fait,
davantage que ce que l’on pense, révèle
ce que l’on croit.
Pour les visuels, je prends des bulles parce
que c’est plus pratique mais il faut donc
préciser :
ce que l’on fait, davantage que ce que l’on
dit, révèle ce qu’on croit.
J’avais déjà un peu abordé cette distinction
dans la vidéo sur la liberté. Je voulais
faire une différence entre croyance consciente
ou de croyance de surface, à laquelle on
a accès immédiatement quand on sonde son
esprit et la croyance profonde, inconsciente,
qui détermine notre manière de vivre plus
ou moins explicitement.
Bref.
Revenons à notre point de départ : l’idée
que croire, c’est tenir pour vrai. Et déjà,
ça pose un énorme problème, parce que ça
suppose de savoir ce qu’on veut dire quand
on dit de quelque chose que c’est vrai.
Et là, déjà, on est bien obligé de reconnaître
qu’on est un peu dans la merde si on veut
se mettre d’accord sur ce qui définit la
vérité.
On distingue plusieurs conceptions de la vérité
et cela mériterait une vidéo à part entière.
Afin d’avancer dans notre réflexion, gardons
à l’esprit que :
la vérité est une valeur. Sauf cas particulier,
nous partons du principe que le vrai vaut
mieux que le faux
le fait de croire est étroitement lié à
l’idée de vérité, et donc à cette distinction.
On ne peut pas croire quelque chose que l’on
tient pour faux.
on conçoit spontanément la vérité comme
transcendante. On ne peut pas décider de
ce qui est vrai. Ce qui est vrai est vrai,
indépendamment de moi. Cela revient généralement
à comprendre la vérité selon un principe
de «fidélité» : une proposition vraie
est une proposition qui décrit fidèlement
le réel. Et l’on part du principe que le
réel est indépendant du regard qu’on porte
sur lui.   Ce dernier point est critique
: c’est un postulat intuitif et largement
partagé mais qu’on gagnerait sans doute
à remettre en cause. Ça aussi, ça devrait
faire l’objet d’une autre vidéo.
Bref, je crois que la critique formulée par
le scepticisme à l’égard de l’astrologie
articule ces trois dimensions.
Il serait problématique de croire en l’astrologie
au sens où cela revient à accorder de la
valeur à un discours, parce qu’on voit
en lui une description fidèle d’un mécanisme
à l’œuvre dans le réel. Or tout porte
à croire que ce discours échoue, précisément,
à décrire fidèlement la réalité.
C’est tout simplement, ce qu’on appelle
«se tromper».
Bon.
Pour y voir plus clair On peut distinguer
deux objets de croyance.
Il y a, d’une part, croire des états de
faits. C’est-à-dire, croire que la superficie
de l’Algérie fait 2 millions 400 mille
km2, croire qu’une molécule d’eau est
composée d’un atome d’oxygène et de
deux atomes d’hydrogène ; croire qu’Emily
Dickinson est née en 1830 et morte en 1886.
Ce sont des choses sues. Des choses qu’on
peut aisément vérifier.
Dans le même sens, on peut croire des hypothèses,
des interprétations qu’on estime théoriquement
vérifiables même si on n’a pas les moyens
sur le moment de procéder à une vérification.
On peut dire que ces hypothèses ont l’ambition
de devenir des faits avérés.
Ainsi, même si ce sont des hypothèses, elles
appartiennent au même registre de croyance
que celui des états de fait.
Parce qu’elles participent cet objectif
de description fidèle du monde.
Et il y a, d’autre part, croire des idées,
des valeurs. Et c’est très différent je
crois.
Mettons qu’Alice me donne un conseil. Elle
me dit, par exemple, que je devrais quitter
mon taff.
Qu’est-ce que cela implique de croire Alice
?
Cela implique, semble-t-il, qu’il est vrai
qu’il est dans mon intérêt de démissionner.
Mais qu’est-ce que cette vérité là ?
Il semble qu’elle soit à jamais invérifiable.
Si je démissionne on ne saura jamais ce qu’aurait
été ma vie si j’avais décidé de rester.
Et si je reste, on ne saura jamais ce que
serait devenue ma vie si j’avais démissionné.
Bon, en un sens, elle est quand même «virtuellement
vérifiable» dans la mesure où on peut
imaginer des mondes parallèles qui permettrait
de faire la comparaison. mais elle est «actuellement
invérifiable» parce qu’on ne pourra
jamais conclure avec suffisamment de certitude.
Pour autant, même si on reconnaît qu’il
est impossible de vérifier rigoureusement
la véracité de la parole d’Alice, on peut
quand même, intuitivement, la trouver plus
ou moins crédible.
On peut y croire ou au contraire en douter.
Pourquoi peut-on croire ou douter d’une
idée invérifiable ?
C’est parce qu’on continue de recevoir
ce type d’énoncé sous le prisme de la
distinction vrai/faux. Même si le conseil
d’Alice est invérifiable, la valeur que
je lui accorde tient à son degré de proximité
à la vérité.
Comme si, au fond, j’étais incapable d’évaluer
une proposition indépendamment de la perspective
de «l’état de fait».
Le conseil d’Alice vaut par sa capacité
à décrire correctement la situation.
On fait comme si on pouvait comparer les deux
mondes, celui où je quitte mon taff et celui
où je reste et on se dit, plus ou moins consciemment,
«le conseil d’Alice est le bon, si, en
comparant ces deux mondes, il apparaît que
je suis plus heureux dans celui où je quitte
mon boulot»
Ce que je veux dire, ici, c’est qu’il
semble que la valeur d’une phrase est souvent
réduite à sa capacité, avérée ou supposée,
à décrire adéquatement ce qui est et ce
qui peut être.
Et en un sens, cela fait tenir la valeur d’une
proposition à sa fidélité à l’existant.
En quel sens ?
Eh bien c’est que la crédibilité d’un
monde possible semble intimement liée à
la «continuité» qu’il tisse avec
le monde d’aujourd’hui et l’état actuel
des connaissances.
Autrement dit : sa crédibilité dépend de
la quantité de ruptures, relativement au
monde qu’on connaît, que son avènement
implique.
Moins il y a de ruptures nécessaire pour
faire advenir ce monde, plus il est crédible.
Et vice versa.
Si j’imagine différents mondes possibles
où je quitte mon taff : 1) dans le premier,
je me découvre une nouvelle passion pour
la finance et je fais fortune à Wall Street
; 2) dans le second, je suis au chômage et
je tombe dans un état dépressif ; 3) dans
le troisième, je me consacre à faire des
vidéos youtube, je retrouve les angoisses
de la précarité mais je profite de ne plus
subir les contraintes liées au salariat
Si le dernier monde me semble le plus crédible,
c’est que c’est celui qui suppose le moins
de discontinuité avec le monde actuel. Il
n’implique pas de sérieux changements dans
ma personnalité ou dans mes compétences
par exemple.
En ce sens, si on fait tenir la valeur d’un
conseil de vie à la crédibilité qu’on
associe au monde possible que le conseil implique,
et si on fait tenir la crédibilité d’un
monde possible à sa proximité avec le monde
que l’on connaît… il semble que cela
conduise à encourager des conseils d’un
certain type – en l’occurrence, des conseils
mesurés, sérieux, ancrés sur l’existant.
Cela suppose donc que l’intérêt ou la
valeur du conseil d’Alice dépend 1) de
l’état du monde tel qu’il est aujourd’hui
; et 2) de sa proximité avec ce monde.
La valeur que j’accorde au conseil d’Alice
tient à sa capacité à dire «vrai»
sur ce que mon monde peut effectivement devenir.
Et donc, de manière plus générale, cela
suppose que toute proposition tournée vers
un autre monde possible, toute phrase construite
autour d’un «devrait» ou «pourrait»
est examinée depuis l’angle du crédible
ou du probable.
Et je crois que ce n’est pas anodin du tout.
2) UN ESPRIT BINAIRE
Donc une question qui m’intéresse désormais
est la suivante : Qu’est-ce que cela pourrait
vouloir dire de recevoir le conseil d’Alice
en dehors de cette interprétation binaire
? indépendamment de sa crédibilité ?
Eh bien, ce pourrait supposer, par exemple,
de m’interroger sur ce que j’aime dans
mon travail aujourd’hui, et au contraire,
ce qui m’ennuie, ce qui me fait peur, ce
qui m’excite, etc.
me faire réfléchir à mes désirs.
Simplement, en observant le genre de sentiments
que la phrase d’Alice provoque en moi.
La phrase d’Alice ne serait plus, en ce
sens, ni vraie ni fausse, elle ne serait pas
jugée en fonction de sa capacité à décrire
plus ou moins fidèlement «ce qui est».
Elle serait plus ou moins stimulante, plus
ou moins enrichissante pour moi qui la reçois.
Elle serait jugée en fonction de sa capacité
à produire en moi de nouvelles pensées.
Vous voyez la différence ? J’espère que
j’arrive à la mettre en valeur !
Encore une fois, cela suppose que c’est
le contexte qui compte. La valeur de la phrase
dépend de celui à qui elle s’adresse,
à quel moment de son existence, dans quelle
situation psychologique, etc.
Je regrette un peu que nos réflexions soient
si souvent définies par cette dichotomie
vrai/faux. C’est très limitant pour la
pensée de fonctionner sur un mode binaire.
Alors je sais bien que certains adeptes du
scepticisme ont envie de m’opposer la carte
Bayes.
Oui, ok, si on pense en termes de probabilités,
alors nos pensées et nos croyances se situent
sur un spectre et échappent à une approche
manichéenne.
Mais ça ne change pas grand chose à ce que
je veux dire.
Parce que la valeur et la signification d’une
croyance reste relative à son positionnement
sur le spectre. Et ce positionnement n’est
déterminable que relativement aux deux extrémités
«vrai/faux».
Je veux bien qu’on dise «rien n’est
vrai ou faux à 100%», et je suis prêt
à accepter que ça change un peu notre rapport
au fait de croire ceci ou cela…
Mais entre nous, ça ne me semble pas bouleverser
notre disposition mentale.
Malgré tout, il existe virtuellement sur
ce spectre, un point qui correspond à «ce
que nous croyons le plus fermement possible»
et un point qui correspond à «ce dont
nous doutons un maximum».
Ces deux points jouent un rôle spécifique
dans notre pensée. Ils mettent un terme à
la croyance. Ils délimitent.
Pour le dire autrement : il est naturel et
intuitif d’avoir avec la croyance la moins
crédible la même relation que celle que
l’on aurait avec une proposition que l’on
jugerait absolument fausse.
Je veux dire que nous percevons, spontanément,
le plus probable comme absolument vrai et
le moins probable comme absolument faux.
Même si on distingue, consciemment, l’extrêmement
probable de l’absolument vrai. Même si
l’on considère que rien n’est absolument
vrai ou absolument faux.
On le ressent comme si c’était absolument
Si je fais une introspection, je suis obligé
de reconnaître que la proposition : «il
y a des licornes au sommet de la tour Eiffel»
m’apparaît, dans mon esprit, comme absolument
fausse. Je ne la ressens pas comme «extrêmement
peu probable» mais comme fausse, tout simplement.
Et si je suis honnête, je dois admettre que
tout un tas de propositions me font exactement
le même effet, quand bien même elles sont
moins improbables que celle-ci.
La proposition «dans 2 ans, le fascisme
aura disparu de la planète» me fait «le
même effet mental» la proposition «il
y a une licorne au sommet de la tour Eiffel».
Mon inconscient les range dans la même case.
Je traite ces croyances exactement comme si
elles étaient absolument fausses. Je ne leur
donne aucune place, aucune fonction dans ma
vie mentale que je refuserais à des croyances
absolument fausses.
Si on parle en termes phénoménologiques,
je veux dire, si l’on se concentre sur la
manière dont ces croyances se manifestent
spontanément dans ma conscience, il est impossible
de les distinguer.
Et cela révèle, je crois, en un sens, une
approche de la croyance plutôt binaire.
Revenons brièvement à l’opposition «représentationalisme
vs. dispositionnalisme» :
Dans le premier cas, la croyance renvoie à
une conception mentale consciente :
Ainsi je crois expérimenter deux types de
croyances selon que je me rapporte à la proposition
«il y a des licornes en haut de la tour
Eiffel» et la proposition «le fascisme
aura disparu en 2024» parce que, quand
j’y pense consciemment, je reconnais une
différence entre ces deux propositions.
si, au contraire, on adopte le dispositionnalisme
selon lequel les croyances renvoient d’abord
et avant tout à un comportement, alors on
voit bien que ces deux propositions renvoient
à un même type de croyance puisque mon comportement
ne diffère pas entre les deux.
Il n’y a donc, de ce point de vue, que deux
familles de comportements possibles :
Soit j’agis comme si X est vrai ou faux
Soit j’agis en fonction de mon degré de
certitude ou d’incertitude relatif à X.
Bref, tout ça pour reconnaître qu’il y
a, malgré toute notre bonne volonté et notre
sérieux, des choses auxquelles on va se rapporter
«comme si elles étaient absolument vraies»
et des choses auxquelles on va se rapporter
«comme si elles étaient absolument fausses».
Et dans la continuité de ce constat, il semble
que l’on rabatte toute croyance sur la dimension
«factuelle», c’est-à-dire descriptive.
Alice me dit que je devrais changer de métier
et mon esprit, spontanément, interroge la
valeur de la proposition d’Alice en termes
factuels : «serais-je effectivement plus
heureux si je change de métier?».
Ou, comme on le disait, en termes descriptifs
: «le monde que décrit implicitement la
proposition d’Alice est-il réellement davantage
plaisant que celui dans lequel je vis présentement
?»
Ce sont, comme vous le voyez, des questions
fermées. On est censés y répondre par oui
ou non. D’où le caractère réducteur et
binaire que je regrette.
3) UNE AUTRE DICHOTOMIE
Je suis donc tenté de proposer une autre
attitude. Une autre manière de recevoir le
conseil d’Alice.
On commencerait par distinguer d’un côté
les paroles d’arrivée et les paroles de
départ.
Une parole d’arrivée, c’est une parole
qui conclue, qui présente un état de fait.
Sa valeur est d’informer. C’est ce qui
correspond à l’approche descriptive. On
décrit ce qui est ou ce qui serait si telle
ou telle circonstances venaient à changer.
Au contraire, une parole de départ, c’est
une parole qui ouvre sur une autre manière
de voir les choses, qui interroge. Sa valeur
est de «donner à penser». Ça ne consiste
pas à décrire ce qui est, ou ce qui serait,
ni même ce qui pourrait être. Cela consiste
à perturber nos habitudes intellectuelles,
à ébranler notre manière d’expérimenter
le monde.
Je peux prendre la proposition d’Alice comme
une parole d’arrivée et donc me demander
si oui ou non, je serais plus heureux en changeant
de métier. Ou, comme on le disait, je peux
la prendre comme une parole de départ et
me demander ce que la remarque m’inspire,
les projections mentales qu’elle fait advenir
en moi, les pressentiments, les craintes,
les aspirations.
Rien n’empêche de combiner les deux.
Ainsi je peux voir le conseil d’Alice, à
la fois comme une parole de départ, qui interroge
mes choix et mes valeurs, et comme une parole
d’arrivée, qui me révèle un état de
fait, ce qu’elle perçoit de ma personne
et qui peut-être m’échappe, par exemple
que mes ami.e.s me perçoivent comme malheureux
au travail.
Par ailleurs, il faut remarquer une autre
dimension de cette opposition.
Dans le cas d’un conseil, comme celui d’Alice,
la valeur d’une parole d’arrivée tient
au crédit accordé à celui ou celle qui
l’énonce. Je peux faire plus ou moins confiance
à la perspicacité d’Alice, par exemple.
Faire confiance à l’hypothèse, c’est
faire confiance au regard qui est à son origine.
Au contraire, la valeur d’une parole de
départ tient à la richesse des idées que
l’on en tire, «à ce qu’on lui fait
dire» voire même «à ce qu’on lui
fait faire». Car la puissance d’une parole
de départ est précisément d’impulser,
dans notre esprit, toute une série d’actions
: évaluer, imaginer, projeter, pressentir…
En un sens, ce sont des responsabilités totalement
opposées. Dans le premier cas, c’est Alice
est responsable de la pertinence de son hypothèse.
Elle me propose une manière d’interpréter
ma vie et la validité de cette interprétation
est fondée sur sa perspicacité, sa justesse
d’analyse, etc.
Dans le second cas, pour la parole de départ,
c’est moi qui suis responsable de l’intérêt
porté à la proposition. Ce qui compte, ce
n'est pas de savoir si l’hypothèse d’Alice
décrit un monde probable, ou crédible. Ce
qui compte, ce sont les images et idées que
mon esprit génère à la rencontre de l’hypothèse
d’Alice.
Tout l’intérêt de ce que dit Alice tient
à ma capacité à en faire quelque chose
de stimulant, quelque chose qui me libère
de ma façon habituelle de voir les choses.
Et donc, si on en revient au problème de
l’astrologie ou du tarot, c’est un peu
pareil.
Mettons qu’on me fait tirer le tarot. Je
pose la question «dois-je changer de métier?».
Je tire les cartes et leur symbolique est
censée m’aider à répondre à la question.
Je tire des cartes et, parce qu’elles disent
toutes quelque chose, parce que le jeu de
tarot est un objet culturel plein de symboliques
et de significations, on peut dire qu’un
tirage de carte tient une forme de discours.
C’est une «parole».
Je tire la carte de la lune et on me donne
sa signification : «c’est le moment d’accalmie
propice à la bonne décision. La lune rappelle
qu’il est temps d’opérer une transition».
Si je prends ça comme une parole d’arrivée,
alors, rappelez-vous, cela suppose que la
responsabilité est dans les cartes elles-mêmes,
c’est-à-dire que la valeur qu’on attribue
au discours que tiennent les cartes relativement
à ma question est fondé sur le tirage, ou
sur la personne qui m’a fait tirer.
Et c’est là qu’intervient quelque chose
comme de la superstition.
Pour que des cartes tirées au hasard puissent
dire quelque chose de pertinent, il faut faire
intervenir une forme de magie. Il faut sous-entendre
qu’elles ne furent pas tirées totalement
au hasard.
C’est-à-dire, pour résumer, par exemple
quelque chose comme : «je crois qu’il
faut que je change de métier parce que les
cartes tirées laissaient entendre que j’avais
grandement besoin de changer mon quotidien
– sous-entendu parce que je crois que par
un procédé mystérieux, les cartes que l’on
tire disent vrai, qu’elles savent effectivement
ce dont j’ai besoin».
La valeur d’un tirage de carte tient entièrement
à l’espèce de «magie» qui doit opérer.
Si les cartes vont vraiment tirées au hasard,
alors le discours ne peut avoir aucune valeur
descriptive.
Mais du point de vue de la parole de départ,
c’est tout à fait différent. Je peux bien
reconnaître que les cartes sont tirées au
hasard, ça ne m’empêche pas d’interroger
ce qu’elles disent. Je peux me voir réagir
au discours qu’elles proposent.
Je peux découvrir que j’ai peur de changer
de métier, si une carte m’y invite.
Je peux réfléchir à ce qui constitue une
«accalmie» dans ma vie et interroger
les décisions que je prends au milieu des
«tempêtes».
Bref, vous voyez l’idée. Je peux recevoir
ça comme une proposition, qui ne m’est
pas personnellement adressé, mais qui m’oblige
à me poser certaines questions, qui me pousse
à réfléchir. Qui m’invite à me projeter,
à pressentir, à visualiser.
Et je crois qu’il est difficile de nier
que cela a de la valeur. Cela donne à penser,
cela fait réfléchir différemment, cela
contraint l’esprit à interpréter à partir
d’un «donné» qui n’est pas habituel,
à partir d’un discours différent, avec
des symboles, des archétypes…
Cela me fait penser en-dehors de mon cadre
habituel de réflexion.
la dichotomie parole d’arrivée et parole
de départ invite aussi à questionner «l’autorité»
d’une parole.
Et là, on en revient à ce que je disais
au tout début de la vidéo, quand je reconnaissais
la potentielle toxicité des discours astrologiques
ou des cartes, etc.
Ce qui est problématique, ce n’est pas
tant qu’une phrase soit «factuellement
fausse». Ce qui est problématique, c’est
que, précisément, on confère une autorité
à ces discours.
Le problème c’est l’autorité elle-même
– c’est parce qu’un discours prétend
dire vrai qu’il devient un devoir qui s'impose
à nous. Une phrase qui prétend dire vrai,
c’est une phrase qui affirme que nous devons
reconnaître que le monde est bel et bien
tel qu’il est décrit par la phrase.
C’est une forme d’ordre : cela dit «votre
expérience de l’existence doit se modeler
sur cette description. Vous devez voir les
choses ainsi».
C’est ça, «la parole d’arrivée».
Et c’est pas rien, ça, quand même. Quand
on le dit comme ça !
Une affirmation à laquelle on reconnaît
une autorité va venir modeler et définir
notre expérience de l’existence.
D’où l’intérêt d’apprendre à nourrir
avec les paroles et les discours un rapport
différent, un rapport où on n’est pas
immédiatement exposé à une modélisation
autoritaire du réel.
Un rapport où on peut, en un sens, «librement»
penser.
Un espace mental où l’on peut réfléchir,
imaginer, inventer des concepts, des idées,
des perspectives sans avoir à répondre à
toute une série de critères qui s’imposent
quand on prétend à la vérité.
Le problème, pour en revenir à notre point
de départ, c’est donc d’enfermer notre
relation à l’astrologie ou à toute autre
pratique du même genre dans cette conception
binaire : soit j’y crois, soit je n’y
crois pas.
Au contraire, une relation rationnelle à
un tel discours doit émerger hors d’une
telle dichotomie. Il ne s’agit ni d’y
croire ni de pas y croire. Il s’agit d’en
faire un tremplin pour penser.
Vous imaginez ce que ça change pour les textes
religieux ?
Si l’on part du principe qu’ils viennent
de D.ieu, et si on a une conception un peu
naïve de D.ieu, je veux dire un dieu personnifié,
qui a des intentions et des pensées comme
un humain, alors le texte est l’autorité
ultime ! Et il doit donc impérativement être
compris, c’est à dire déchiffré, décrypté…
Ce qui est une relation à un texte somme
toute assez banale et peut-être même réductrice.
En ce sens, le texte religieux est la parole
d’arrivée par excellence. Et elle porte
une vérité supposément définitive et absolue.
Si, au contraire, on aborde ces textes avec
l’état d’esprit propre à la parole de
départ, une attitude qui me semble d’ailleurs
compatibles avec d’autres conceptions du
divin, si on y cherche des images, des sensations,
des pressentiments, des réactions… Il est
possible, sans même adhérer à la foi en
question, d’en tirer une expérience très
riche.
4) SOYONS PRAGMATIQUES
Au fond, sans doute peut-on faire un parallèle
avec la fiction. Vous lisez un roman, vous
regardez un film, une série… même si ce
qui est raconté ne renvoie en rien à des
faits établis, vous pouvez quand même en
tirer une expérience intéressante
La fiction peut transformer notre façon de
voir le monde, de le comprendre, qui fait
bouger nos critères, nos préjugés, etc.
Ce n’est pas sans valeur !
Quand on expérimente de la fiction, on entre
plus volontiers dans l’état d’esprit
«parole de départ».
Vous vous souvenez de cette intervention
de Ricky Gervais ?
Je ferai bientôt une vidéo sur les croyances
religieuses et je m’attarderai davantage
dessus à ce moment là. Mais je voudrais
quand même relever quelque chose dès maintenant.
Ce discours est une belle illustration de
ce qu’on pourrait appeler, pompeusement,
la «reductio ad factum».
Si l’humanité repartait zéro, elle produirait
la même science, dit-il. Bon, déjà, on
peut sérieusement en douter, mais ce n’est
même pas le sujet ici.
Ricky Gervais semble affirmer que seul ce
qui est factuel est digne d’être valorisé.
Ce qui repose sans doute sur une conception
assez simpliste de ce qui constitue un «fait».
Mais à la limite, peu importe : si l’humanité
repartait de zéro, elle ne produirait sans
doute pas, à l’identique, les mêmes films,
les mêmes livres, les mêmes chansons…
Or, la valeur que ces productions ont dans
nos vies ne tient pas à leur capacité à
décrire des «états de fait».
Au contraire, elles inventent, proposent,
imaginent, projettent, envisagent, soulignent…
Pour le dire autrement : ce n’est pas parce
qu’une chose ne prétend pas décrire «La
Réalité» qu’elle est dénuée de toute
valeur !
Ce n’est pas parce que les cartes sont tirées
au hasard, ce n’est pas parce que mon destin
n’est pas effectivement lié aux planètes
qu’un tirage ou un thème ne peut provoquer
en moi des réflexions fines et pertinentes.
Le problème, c’est donc notre tendance
à tout recevoir comme parole d’arrivée.
C’est un mauvais réflexe !
Cela fait dépendre la valeur d’une proposition,
d’une phrase, d’une idée, de l’existant
et du possible. C’est à dire que cela réduit
la valeur de la pensée à ce qui est et à
ce qui peut être à l’intérieur du monde
tel qu’on le connaît déjà.
C’est une forme de défense du statu quo.
C’est ne donner de la valeur qu’à ce
qui existe et ce qui peut exister. Et ce «qui
peut exister» dépend étroitement de ce
qui existe. Ce qui peut advenir est, par définition,
une continuation de ce qui est déjà.
Puisque ce qui est advient est causé par
ce qui est déjà.
De sorte qu’on s’empêche toute rupture,
toute pensée capable de faire rupture, capable
de provoquer une réelle différence dans
notre regard.
La parole d’arrivée est évaluée en fonction
de sa crédibilité, c’est-à-dire de sa
compatibilité avec le monde tel qu’on le
connaît.
La parole de départ est évaluée en fonction
des ouvertures qu’elle propose, des bouleversements
qu’elle provoque.
La première arrête tandis que la seconde
met en mouvement.
La première confirme l’existant, la seconde
ouvre sur ce qui déborde l’existant, sur
ce que l’on était incapable d’imaginer.
Bien sûr, nous avons besoin de paroles d’arrivées.
Il ne s’agit pas, ici, de leur refuser tout
intérêt ! Mais je crois qu’on gagnerait
à faire un peu plus de place aux paroles
de départ.
Je disais au début de la vidéo que nos critiques
de l’astrologie étaient révélatrices.
Et qu’elles mettaient en lumière un danger
pour la pensée.
Eh bien voilà : elles révèlent notre propension
à évaluer toute proposition en termes de
crédibilité relative à ce qui est déjà
connu.
Et le danger, c’est donc qu’en cultivant
cette tendance, nous limitons notre capacité
à produire des idées différentes de celles
qui dominent notre expérience. Nous limitons
la plasticité de notre regard sur le monde.
Au contraire : nous prenons le risque de nous
enfermer dans nos habitudes de pensée.
Nous ne valorisons plus que le connu et le
connaissable. Nous nous coupons de l’inimaginable.
Et cela pose plus largement la question de
la place (et de la valeur) que l’on accorde
au discours dont l’intérêt ne repose pas
sur la description. Dont l’intérêt ne
tient pas à la fidélité de la description.
Donc quid de la fiction ? Faut-il la réduire
à du plaisir ? N’est-elle pas plus qu’une
friandise pour l’esprit ?
Et si nous faisons de la fiction un moyen
détourné d’apprendre sur nous-même et
sur le monde, n’est-ce pas, au fond, une
manière de la rabattre sur cet idéal descriptif
? La fiction ne pourrait-elle être une ouverture
sur une autre réalité, suivant d’autres
règles, d’autres systèmes de valeurs ?
Quid de la philosophie ? Je veux dire de la
philosophie qui ne prétend pas participer
à la grande quête scientifique de description
du réel. La philosophie qui crée des concepts,
qui fabrique une langue, qui transforme nos
affects ? Pourquoi fait-on si peu de place
à ces discours qui cherchent moins à décrire
la vie qu’à la changer ?
Et enfin quid de la religion ? de la théologie
? Quel rapport pouvons-nous tisser à ces
discours si nous nous libérons de cette dichotomie
? Quelle ampleur le concept de D.ieu peut-il
prendre, si on ne se borne pas à se demander
s’il faut y croire ou non ? Quelle serait
une relation au concept de D.ieu libéré
de la problématique de la croyance ? Voilà
une question vertigineuse !
Bref.
Voici mon hypothèse : je crois que la vérité
comme idéal, la vérité comme horizon vers
lequel nous faisons tendre notre pensée,
suppose qu’il existe quelque chose qui puisse
«valider» notre représentation du monde.
Et cette chose, c’est sans doute ce qu’on
appelle «Réalité».
Or, nous ne déconstruisons pas suffisamment
le concept de réalité. Nous le prenons pour
acquis. La réalité, pense-t-on, c’est
ce qui me précède et me succède, ce qui
existe sans moi.
A cet égard, La Réalité est la grande autorité
transcendante. C’est ce qu’on ne saurait
remettre en cause. C’est ce à quoi nous
devons nous soumettre. Un peu comme D.ieu
du coup.
Quand bien même on concèderait que nos représentations
mentales du monde ne pourront jamais atteindre
«La Réalité», quand bien même on
n’en ferait qu’un idéal régulateur,
elle représente malgré tout un «critère
absolu» à l’aune duquel on va juger
les propositions.
Nous croyons alors qu’il existe une instance,
certes impersonnelle et dénuée d’intention,
à partir de laquelle nous pouvons évaluer
nos pensées et croyances. Plus elles semblent
conformes à La Réalité, plus elles ont
de valeur.
Tant que notre pensée est enfermée dans
la binarité «y croire ou ne pas y croire»,
nous restons esclaves du fantasme de la transcendance.
Aussi voyons-nous par exemple l’ivresse
ou les expériences associées au psychotropes
comme des états «confus», des égarements
passagers. On parle d’états modifiés de
conscience, comme partant du principe que
la conscience quotidienne est un état «normal»
– l’état le plus fidèle à La Réalité.
Nous nous empêchons d’expérimenter, nous
appauvrissons notre relation à l’existence
parce que nous avons peur de l’erreur, de
la tromperie, du mensonge.
Parce que nous n’avons pas appris à vivre
par-delà la distinction vrai/faux. Parce
que nous avons un désir quasi insatiable
de Vérité, de Réalité. Peut-être parce
que La Réalité, La Vérité, c’est l’autorité,
et c’est donc le pouvoir.
Qu’il est rassurant de penser qu’on dit
vrai !
5) OUVERTURE : CROYANCE ET EXISTENCE
On n’échappe pas à la question «que
faut-il croire» ?
Cette question est rigolote si on la décortique.
D’un côté, on a «croire» qui renvoie,
intuitivement, à la connaissance et à la
vérité. Soit ce qu’on croit est vrai,
soit c’est faux. On ne pense pas spontanément
à autre chose quand il est question de croyance.
De l’autre côté, on a «falloir»
qui renvoie directement à l’idée de devoir,
et donc à la morale. Elle fait écho à La
question «que faut-il faire? » qui a
d’évidentes implications éthiques.
Et donc, la question «que faut-il croire?»,
je crois qu’elle est héritière de la sainte
trinité qu’on trouve déjà chez Platon
et qui articule le beau, le bien le vrai.
«Que faut-il croire ? Le vrai. Car le vrai
est forcément bon.» Voilà ce qui s'impose
à notre intuition.
Mais on gagnerait à interroger ce présupposé
!
Car au fond, rien ne nous empêche de libérer
nos croyances de cette conception disons «réaliste»
de la vérité.
Ce qu’il «faut croire», ou ce qu’il
«convient de croire», ou ce qu’on
a «intérêt de croire».. c’est est
une question morale, politique et, également,
une question existentielle, avant d’être
une question épistémique, avant d’être
une affaire de connaissance.
Et tout ça simplement à cause du verbe falloir,
au fond.
on peut facilement expliquer l’intuition
selon laquelle il faut croire le vrai.
Et ce qui fonderait ce devoir, ce serait,
tout simplement, l’idéal d’harmonie sociale.
Ce serait là que reposerait la «valeur
politique» de la vérité.
Le vrai, c’est ce qui met d’accord. C’est
ce qui «oblige à se mettre d’accord».
La vérité est une sanction. Quand deux individus
voient les choses différemment, ils peuvent
être contraints de se plier à l’autorité
qu’incarne le vrai. Leur désaccord est
écrasé par la vérité. Ça règle les conflits.
Que l’on considère la vérité comme une
transcendance ou comme une construction sociale
et culturelle, elle jouit inévitablement
d’une forme d’autorité.
Bon. Ce qui est vraiment terrible avec ce
genre de vidéos c’est qu’il y a des embranchements
possibles, voire nécessaires, toutes les
30 secondes.
Là, j’aimerais ajouter une parenthèse
de 20 min autour de cette tension vertigineuse
qui affleure quand on évoque l’horizon
d’une «harmonie sociale».
Vous le savez déjà sans doute, je n’ai
pas spécialement envie de protéger le statu
quo.
Aussi n’ai-je pas du tout envie de stigmatiser
les comportements qu’on qualifie parfois
de marginaux et, plus généralement, les
comportements susceptibles de déstabiliser
l’organisation sociale.
Au contraire, même. J’ai plutôt l’impression
que l’ordre établi est non seulement injuste
mais trop autoritaire.
Et quand je dis autoritaire, cela renvoie
donc aussi bien aux comportements qu’aux
croyance. La société est un espace normé
et contraignant. Certes.
Critiquer cette dimension autoritaire et contraignante,
cela ne suppose pas de nier l’existence
de comportements toxiques – des comportements
que l’on veut donc légitimement voir disparaître.
Et bien sûr que nos comportements sont étroitement
liés à nos croyances.
Donc à la question «que faut-il croire
?», e comprends bien que on peut avoir
envie de répondrej : «il faut adopter
les croyances qui ne génèrent pas de comportements
toxiques».
Il faut éviter ce qui fait souffrir autrui,
tout simplement.
Intuitivement, c’est ce que je soupçonne
derrière l’idéal d’harmonie sociale.
Un monde où on fait le maximum pour que les
gens souffrent le minimum
Et comme on disait, il y a une espèce d’association
spontanée qui suppose que la vérité est
forcément belle et bonne.
Cela nous invite à déduire que la vérité
va nous rapprocher de cet idéal d’harmonie
sociale, que si tout le monde connaissait
la vérité, le monde irait forcément mieux,
voire, il serait aussi bon que possible.
Sans doute qu’il y a là quelque chose qu’on
peut identifier historiquement. Le culte du
progrès, progrès technique ou progrès de
la raison, est un mythe qu’il est tenté
d’associer à cette confusion Vrai-Bien.
Que faut-il croire ? Le vrai ! Parce que du
vrai ne peut rien découler de mauvais.
Mais comme on ne questionne pas fondamentalement,
rigoureusement, profondément ce qu’on appelle
vrai, ça devient, sans surprise : «les
meilleures croyances que l’on peut adopter
sont celles qui sont fondées sur une description
fidèle de la réalité».
Alors qu’on pourrait se dire, par exemple
: «les meilleures croyances sont celles
qui transforment notre rapport au monde dans
le sens que l’on souhaite».
C’est une position pragmatiste, mais là
encore, il faudrait une vidéo à part là-dessus.
Une première chose que je veux partager avec
vous, c’est l’intérêt de distinguer
la valeur épistémique des croyances de leur
valeur morale.
En gros : c’est pas parce qu’une croyance
est solide sur le plan épistémique qu’elle
en devient automatiquement légitime du point
de vue moral. Et par conséquent, ce n’est
pas parce que notre croyance n’est pas robuste
sur le plan épistémique que c’est une
croyance moralement problématique.
Donc : la quête de vérité n’est pas un
impératif moral. C’est un choix existentiel.
En réalité une fois la valeur morale de
la croyance assurée, on peut croire ce qu’on
veut.
Si d’un côté, on fait tout ce qu’on
peut pour participer à rendre la société
la plus juste possible*, on peut tout se permettre,
on peut chercher à adopter les croyances
les plus enrichissantes.
La question qui m’intéresse, c’est donc
plutôt «que peut-on croire ?». Et ici
«pouvoir» renvoie bien à une capacité.
Qu’est-ce que je suis capable de croire
? Quelle relation à l’expérience suis-je
capable de tisser ?
Et poser les choses ainsi, ça me fait penser
à la drogue et plus particulièrement à
l’image sociale des usagers de drogue. Parce
qu’il y a là de forts enjeux politiques
et philosophiques, notamment autour des questions
de normes et de marginalité, autour des questions
de santé, de puissance, de valeur et de signification
de l’expérience.
Je prépare depuis longtemps un script sur
la question, parce que c’est un sujet qui
compte énormément pour moi.
Donc, sans rentrer dans le détail, je voudrais
juste dire qu’il y a une sorte de «méfiance»,
de la part de l’opinion publique, à l’égard
des usagers de drogues, précisément parce
qu’ils semblent «refuser» la «réalité»
de tout le monde. En un sens, parce qu’ils
créent leur propre réalité. Comme si la
société leur en voulait de s’échapper
dans un autre monde, de produire un autre
système de valeurs que celui qu’on tente
de leur imposer.
Et je crois que si les usagers de drogue ont
«mauvaise réputation» dans la société,
si leur mode de vie est stigmatisé, c’est
précisément à cause de cette espèce d’obsession
pour la «vérité en tant que norme».
Je ne parle pas d’une quête obsessionnelle
pour la «vérité» mais bien de ce besoin
d’autorité que traduit le besoin de vérité.
C’est une espèce de triangulaire conceptuelle.
D’abord, elle est une transcendance. Pour
que la vérité ait de la valeur, il faut
qu’elle me dépasse. Il ne peut pas être
de mon ressort de décider de ce qui est vrai
ou faux.
Donc, logiquement, elle renvoie à l’idée
de Réalité. Ce qui crée une espèce d’équivalence
dans notre esprit. La réalité, comme la
vérité, c’est ce qui ne dépend pas de
moi.
Et en un sens, c’est ce qui s’oppose à
moi, ce qui me contraint, ce qui m’oblige.
Donc c’est aussi une norme. C’est ce qui
va orienter mon comportement et donc mon expérience.
La norme renvoie inévitablement au devoir.
Parce que c’est le comportement socialement
accepté, celui qu’on nous encourage à
adopter. C’est le comportement valorisé.
C’est ce qu’il convient de faire.
D’où l’idée qu’il faut croire ce qui
décrit adéquatement la réalité.
D’où l’idée qu’une croyance épistémiquement
valide est forcément aussi moralement valide.
Les trois pointes du triangle se renforcent
mutuellement. Ça devient très difficile
de s’en libérer.
Et donc, pour en revenir à la drogue : le
sentiment qui nous fait penser que l’expérience
vécue par l’entremise d’un psychotrope
n’est pas vraiment «la réalité»
est intimement lié au triangle.
Dans l’imaginaire collectif, c’est l’envers
de ce triangle.
Commençons pas l’aspect transcendant de
la vérité. Eh bien on reproche à l’expérience
avec psychotropes d’être un genre de bulle,
de rêve, de n’exister que dans la tête
de celui ou celle qui la vit. Ça ne vaut
rien parce que ça ne vaut pour personne d’autre.
En gros.
Dans le même ordre d’idée, sans surprise,
l’expérience est qualifiée d’illusoire.
On se moquera plus ou moins gentiment des
prises de conscience ou des épiphanies vécues
à l’aide d’une drogue. Parce que cette
expérience est différente de celle qu’on
a l’habitude de faire au quotidien, alors
elle est forcément erronée. C’est l’idée
que notre cerveau fonctionne bien en temps
normal et qu’il fonctionne de travers quand
on prend une substance.
Enfin, logiquement, le fait de valoriser de
telles expériences renvoie à un comportement
qu’on stigmatise injustement à mon sens,
comme déviant. Ces expériences sont, tout
simplement, différentes de celles que vivent
la plupart des gens. En cela, elles paraissent
aux yeux de la société, incompatibles avec
les exigences d’une vie sociale harmonieuse.
Je fais ce petit détour par l’usage de
drogue simplement pour mettre en lumière
la pression sociale à adopter certains comportements
et certaines croyances.
Cette idée selon laquelle «il faut croire
ce qui est réel»
Et ici «réel» renvoie à une conception
super étroite, autoritaire et normée de
la réalité.
Or, je le répète, je crois qu’on a intérêt
à déconstruire cette attitude.
Imaginons qu’Alice a des croyances super
étranges. Elle est persuadée d’être dans
le rêve de quelqu’un. C’est même pas
elle qui rêve, c’est toute son existence
qui est le produit du rêve d’une personne.
C’est quand même sacrément différent
de ce que nous croyons tous. Pour Alice, ce
qu’elle nomme «réalité» n’a pas
du tout le même sens.
Et, mettons que cette croyance rend Alice
particulièrement heureuse. Être un rêve
lui donne l’impression que chacune de ses
expériences est incroyablement précieuse.
Parallèlement si Alice est tout de même
respectueuse des individus qu’elle «croise»
dans sa réalité-rêve, si elle s’investit
dans la société, si elle adhère à une
morale, si elle a de la compassion… Pourquoi
devrait-elle abandonner sa croyance ?
Sa réalité est peut-être incompatible avec
la nôtre sur le plan épistémique mais elle
ne l’est pas sur le plan moral et politique.
la question de savoir ce qu’il «convient
de croire» n’est pas une question épistémologique.
C’est une question philosophique.
Nous n’avons aucune légitimité de demander
à Alice d’abandonner sa croyance.
Nous ne sommes concernés que par les comportements
des gens, pas ce qu’ils croient et pensent.
Je ne nie pas que les croyances et les comportements
sont liés bien sûr. Je dis qu’il est malhonnête
de partir du principe que les croyances farfelues
impliquent nécessairement un comportement
néfaste ou toxique pour les autres.
Et donc, c’est une manière de dire que
la valeur épistémique d’une croyance n’est
pas la seule qui compte.
Il y a la valeur morale, celle qui tient au
comportement causé par la croyance.
Et il y a la valeur existentielle. Celle qui
renvoie à la richesse de l’expérience.
Richesse sensible, perceptive, émotionnelle,
intellectuelle…
Certaines croyances donnent plus à vivre,
plus à sentir, plus à penser que d’autres.
Distinguons ces trois aspects de la croyance
!
Reprenons Alice et observons sa croyance sous
le prisme de ces trois valeurs.
Et regardons Bob, un chirurgien athée qui
se qualifie de rationaliste-sceptique.
A valeur morale égale, quelle croyance choisissez-vous
? Et pourquoi ?
La valeur existentielle, c’est un peu ce
qui est en jeu dans une certaine philosophie
et une certaine littérature
je regrette qu’on ne mette pas l’accent
sur la capacité de ces textes à transformer
notre expérience de la vie.
je regrette qu’au lycée ou à l’université,
on en fait des objets d’étude plutôt que
des objets d’expérience.
je regrette qu’on en fasse un élément
de distinction sociale plutôt qu’un outil
pour explorer l’existence.
nos croyances forment le tissu de nos expériences.
Elles en définissent la couleur, la profondeur,
l’intensité…
Il est possible de construire des croyances
qui enrichissent terriblement l’existence.
Mais on ne semble obsédé que par la connaissance,
que par la valeur épistémique, que par l’autorité
que la vérité confère…
A côté de quelles vies possibles passons-nous
?! A quel point notre expérience de la vie
pourrait-elle être plus profonde ?